a Colorado man will spend the rest of
his life behind bars for murdering his
fiancee yesterday a jury convicted
Patrick Frazee after after deliberating
rather for just three and a half hours a
judge sentenced Frazee to life plus 156
years without parole for beating Kelsie
Bharath to death her body has never been
found
Nikki Bateses in [ __ ] Creek Colorado
Nikki the prosecution's star witness now
they face sentencing next what do you
think we can expect on that especially
since it didn't take them long to
convict Patrick crazy gale good morning
well Patrick Frazee secret girlfriend
crystal Lee is expected to be sentenced
for evidence tampering
as early as her next court appearance on
December 2nd she testified that Frazee
asked her to kill Bharath three times
and yesterday prosecutors for the first
time were blunt about wily's testimony
was critical we absolutely did a deal
with the devil in this case but we did a
deal with the devil in order to solve
this case moments after Patrick Frazee
was sentenced for killing his fiancee
Kelsie Bharath prosecutors revealed they
were shocked when Krystal Lee admitted
she cleaned up the crime scene and
prosecutors say Frazee felt no remorse
for what he did he based on my
observations of Patrick Frazee over the
last year that there's a potential that
Patrick Frazee indicates and is
consistent with a sociopath Lee an Idaho
nurse says Frazee had asked her to kill
Bharath three times and when she didn't
he did she says Frazee told her he beat
Bharath with a baseball bat on
Thanksgiving Day and after called her
and said she had a mess to clean up in
exchange for her testimony Lee agreed to
plead guilty to evidence tampering and
faces a maximum of three years in prison
a lot of our viewers are gonna say how
does crystal Lee only face three years
in prison
Krystal Lee deserves every day that she
gets in and whatever the judge picks for
her sentence and then some Bharath body
has never been found
neither has a murder weapon what is the
motive so I can't tell you if it's a
single thing or it's multiple things we
can guess at it but it's totally against
klein who has known Frazee for years sat
through the trial
do you by Crystal story I'm not saying
that I don't believe Kelsie's data I
just I don't see it happening like it
was laid out crystal Lee testified that
beareth and Frazee's infant daughter was
in the next room at the time of the
murder
Barris mother who has been caring for
the now two-year-old little girl told
the court room Tony she wants to adopt
her granddaughter
a little bit of good news there at the
end Nicky thank you very much